hey everyone
uh I guess let's get started
um so today we're going to talk about a
kernel method so I'm going to Define
what it is so in some sense this is a
general technique uh for dealing with
non-linear averity in your data so um
um oh we're going to see more other
General techniques like new light works
but this is one of the techniques that
we will deal with nonlinearity before
deep learning took off
and we'll introduce these techniques
mostly in the setting of super asserting
in the kind of the discriminative
algorithm type of settings so
um but this kind of techniques can also
applies to Enterprise Learning or other
settings
um just with similar type of ideas
okay so I guess so let me start by um I
guess start with a random example so
suppose you have some data I guess I'm
thinking about surprise learning just a
simple kind of like
regression settings right so you have
some acts and you have some Y and you
have some data something like this
I'm destroying something
I'm making up some data
and in the first two weeks I think Chris
talked about you know you fake a linear
regression right so that's that means
that you have to you're filter some
linear model on top of this
so but you can see that you know
I'm I designed this data such that you
know a linear model is probably not
correct right so apparently in this data
you know you may want to use
some something like maybe a cubic
polynomial
and if you have done the homework
um I think there's one homework question
which actually also talks about you know
how do you deal with this kind of
situation where your data is not linear
in X right so you shouldn't you assume a
linear model in X the homework is still
this Wednesday right yeah so it's one of
the last homework questions but you
don't have to know the exactly the
homework questions I'm going to actually
um
um basically kind of review the homework
questions to some extent so how do you
deal with this kind of case right so
um so a simple way to do it is the
following so you say I'm going to have a
Q back polynomial to fade this data so
basically I'm going to assume that
um model is something like H state of X
is a function of X parameters by Theta
so it's something like theta 3 times x
cubed plus Theta Square Times x squared
sorry see there's two times x square
plus Theta 1 x 1 plus Theta zero so here
my Axis uh is a real number just for the
sake of Simplicity
um
so I have this uh
non-linear model
and
um
sorry any questions
okay so uh you fit this right so how do
you deal with this so one thing to
realize is that either you have such a
model that is non-linear in x
but actually this is linear
in Theta
right it's a linear function of theta
it's a nonlinear function of x
so but actually when you really do
linear regression it really doesn't
matter whether it's linear X or not
what really matters whether you are
linear in your parameter because you are
optimizing over the parameter space
so in other words more especially so
what you can do is that you can turn
this into a linear a standard linear
regression Problem by doing a simple
change
so you can say that I'm going to Define
this function Phi of x
um
to be
this function that Maps a to this vector
so this function maybe you should record
five of maybe let's just call it Phi Phi
is a function in maths R to r four
and then you can rewrite this
non-linear model non-linear X
um to be something more like a linear
model
like this is almost exactly the same as
um
the linear model we have talked about
right so this is a vector say the ones
something like this
times
1 x x square X cubed
which you can write this as
Theta transpose times Phi of x
so in some sense after you do this
simple rewriting right now H Theta
X
linear
in Theta I still linear in Theta and
also is linear in the coordinate of Phi
of x
so this is how you make everything
linear and then you can in some sense
invoke
um the linear regression
algorithm that you have used what does
that mean that means that you basically
can just view this as your new input so
before your input was X right now input
becomes higher dimensional before input
was one dimensional X right and now
input becomes
uh field facts which is a
four-dimensional vector
um and and that's it
so in other words suppose before we have
a data set which is X1 y1
up to x n y n where X
is a scalar the input is scalar y i is
always a scalar I say
and now in some sense you just turn this
into
you can turn this into a new data set
and this little set is going to be the
input will be Phi of x i
and the label or the output is the same
of course your input dimensionality
becomes formal instead of one but we
have we are able to deal with high
dimensional input for leading regression
right so so basically you know you can
just know
um view this
as you're new
inputs
or sometimes people call it features
I guess probably you know we have talked
about this like features sometimes is a
is a word that is has multiple
similar meanings in machine learning so
um
so so in many cases features just means
inputs
um but I'll clarify you know in earlier
uh situations sometimes features means
slightly different things
um
but sometimes you can just say this this
is a new input this is a new output the
new out to be the same and you just work
on linear regression on a new data set
and that's how you learn a cubic
function for this data set right by
turning it by kind of reducing it to a
linear regression problem
and I think this is a piece that
one
I think it's Q4 but maybe we change the
order
um of this of the questions a little bit
um
right any questions so far
[Music]
uh how do I know this is better than
that what yeah
this transformation
uh then no transformation
okay so yeah so I guess it's just uh you
know you you know of course eventually
you have to validate your method and see
how it works but the intuition so here
I'm not saying it's better I'm just
saying that if you believe that you
should use a cubic function this is how
you implement it right so whether you
believe that you should use the cubic
functions of a linear function that
depends on the property for data maybe
you should experiment with it you should
probably look at data to see whether it
is a linear function there are other
ways to decide you know which model we
want to use I think actually in two or
three lectures uh later we're going to
talk about how do you pick different
models
okay so yeah so exactly I think so this
is a way to implement
a cubic function uh at least for one
dimension
okay and and what you um gonna do is the
following so
um so how how do you proceed right so
like you basically just uh you know
repeat what we have knew about we have
no about like a linear regression you
just write down an algorithm uh on this
data set right and and implemented
linear regression algorithm on this data
set I'm going to
um repeat the procedures but this is
basically just exactly you just invoke
what we have learned uh from the first
two weeks but I'm going to repeat it
because uh this part I'm going to use it
we use it again to demonstrate uh
something else to demonstrate a kernel
trick so
um so how do we really do this so if you
do linear regression
on this new data set
so I guess let's say we use green reset
okay so let's use green descent
and so on the loss function
something like that's right
you compare your label
with
um
uh with um you know suppose you have fun
you compare a label with
uh the model which is V of x i
and square
right recall that you know if you do the
standard linear regression what will
happen is that
um for the standard case then this will
be x i
and this will be x i
in the most standard case and what I'm
doing here is just replacing that x i by
Phi of x i
and then if you work within yourself
what's the formula the formula would be
something like you have to have a loop
right so and each time you are updating
your Theta
um by theta plus
some learning rate times
the gradient and the gradient if you
compute it it will be something like y
I minus Theta transpose Phi of x i
times V of XL
and for the standard case then this two
two things will just be both x i
if you look up the lecture notes there
will be dispose of both x i and now they
becomes this Transformer transformed
version of this I guess so the quest
teaching this location like this is
supposed to be that you update your
status by Theta process that's the
notation makes sense
okay sounds good so you know it's in
some sense just a short hand you know
you know if you really want to be very
kind of like if you really read a
mathematical paper maybe they will call
Theta t plus one is equal to Theta t
plus this
I'm saying that in a standard case this
will be x i in the in the in the first
two weeks now I just replace it yeah
all right okay so
um and there's some small differences
which is that you know if in the
standard case so now what's the
dimension of theta the dimension of
theta is not the same as the dimension
of the X right so suppose you say X
is of Dimension Rd
um maybe I should use black color just
to be more consistent so and
po Fox is a function that Maps
Rd to some other dimension it doesn't
have to be exactly the same Dimension
right before we map from one dimension
to four dimension but you can from any
Dimension to other dimension so let's
call this Dimension P so p is the
dimension of the so-called new feature
the in the new inputs
so and that means that your Theta also
has to be in the same space as V because
your Theta will be a linear combination
of the transform inputs so Theta is also
living in this space
so so so basically we are updating
um
in this P dimensional space instead of X
dimensional space
and and let me also just briefly talk
about the terminology so I guess so I
think this is often called a feature map
so and
and this V of x
maybe I think I should call this like
something like this maybe the right
notation should be this so fees as a
function it maps from RD to RP and P of
X I think people often call this at
least in this context called these
features
and if you look at you know this kind of
like papers or kind of research in this
context often people call X the
attributes
just to distinguish it from the features
um you know the terminology doesn't
really matter that much like in most of
cases you can infer the term terms if
you really know what they uh they mean
so
um
but I'm just uh giving you some kind of
context when if you read the paper which
says that access the attributes and fear
facts the features they know what they
mean but sometimes other papers would
call it differently maybe some people
would call Access raw features and call
these features you know they are there
are multiple ways to name them which is
a little bit unfortunate
um okay
um anyway so but feature map I think
people always call this feature map
maybe sometimes people call this feature
extractor
um um but they all mean the same thing
and
I guess maybe let's just so my
extrapolation from reading all of these
papers I realized that features you know
even though sometimes they mean
different things often at least from my
statistical learning inference of this
world I think this word seems to mean it
always means that something that you use
a linear function on top of these things
so basically if you're there's a linear
thing on top of something and then that
something will be called features like
uh
um you know just uh so so basically like
uh it often refers to those variables in
which you have a linear
you have a your model is linear
okay so are we done right so um this
sounds great right so everything is so
clear and simple nothing seems to be
complicated you just replace x i by feel
flexor so
um so but we are not done so why because
you know in some cases this is great
right so
um like for example example of the
homework question if you look at it but
we basically ask you exactly Implement
something like this I think we ask you
to implement a different algorithm we
didn't ask you to implement the green
infant we ask you to implement the uh
the you use the the exact solver use the
the
um the inverse of the the time some
Matrix some Greenies kind of things so
um but you know but the same thing right
you just apply your existing algorithm
on this new data set
um but but this is not done because you
know because of efficiency issue but I
have I think I saw a question yeah
why is it why is it hot here I think
this is the so that's the gradient
doesn't have
like a it doesn't really matter right
but but if you have a half then you
always agree in front of the green
there's no two it's just convention
I think if you I think if you read the
the the the first two weeks also we have
a half right typically there's a half
um
um okay so
um all right so okay so while we are not
done the reason is that sometimes
there's an efficiency issue uh with this
with this kind of approach and the
reason is that this feature map can be
very high dimensional so P can be very
large
in some cases
for example suppose you know in this
case p is four right so it's which
sounds kind of pretty fun but what if
your ax is High dimensional right so
here x is one dimensional and p uh the
features are p is four dimensional but
what if you say I'm going to have a x
1 up to XD right I have D coordinates in
my raw data
and now if I want to create
something
like this
um that have all the
the common the cubic monomials of the of
the coordinates then what you have to do
is that you're gonna have something like
Phi of X needs to be something like
a gigantic Vector where maybe you have
one here you have X1 X2 all the degree
uh one
um monomials of the coordinates and then
you have the degree two I think x minus
two maybe you should start with X Y
Square x one times X1 X1 X2
up to X by x d now X2 X1 so and so forth
maybe maybe x 2 x 1 can be omitted
because there is a repetition but it
doesn't really change the point
um so you're gonna have need to have a
very long Vector that lists all the
possible combinations the products of
these coordinates right so you're going
to have like
maybe X1 Cube up to eventually x d cubed
something like this
so and only when you have this then you
can claim all the degree three
polynomials can be written as a linear
function of this of these features
right so and
so so and and then what is p what was
the dimensionality of this new features
so if you contact right so there is
so I'm going to do some rough content so
this one there's one one and for this
kind of like degree one thing you have D
of this
right and for the grade two thing I
guess uh
so you're gonna have degree two thing
maybe
so there are d square of this let's say
we ignore the reputations you know the
reputations only change the constant
factor which doesn't really change the
point
um so you have d square and then for
degree three thing you you can start
from X1
X1 cubed 2x D Cube and with all the
combinations you're gonna have D cube of
this terms
I guess this is a little bit
okay okay so right so then this means
that
um so even though you know of course
every so every the good thing is every
degree three polynomial
can be written as you know can be
written as some
but the bad news is that V of x
is in this RP where
p is something like the
D Cube
um you know technically B P I see in
this case you know if if I do this p is
equals to 1 plus this plus d square plus
d Cube
um the dominating term is D Cube and
this is very high dimensional uh Vector
so if you think about this uh for
example let's say
maybe you suppose
this is just a back of envelope
calculation suppose these 10 to the
three say a thousands then P will be
a billion
so and and why this is a problem this is
a problem because if you run algorithm
this algorithm
then how many iterations how many uh how
much computation you have to pay here so
if we look at this
so
I guess if you count how how much
competition we have to pay
this product requires
of P computation
right all p in the so you are taking the
product of two inner paradoxical two uh
to two vectors to P dimensional vectors
you have to pay P numerical like
operations right P multiplications and
you also have to sum the sum also has P
operations so it's all of P operations
for this in the product and a name it
becomes scalar and you you take the
difference between this and this that's
fine and then you multiply by this which
also
uh this is scalar times this which still
takes all P operations so evaluating
this whole thing
takes off P operations that's still kind
of okay but you have to have take this
out and there's a multiplicative Factor
because you have to wait you know
repeatedly so totally evaluating this
the whole thing takes off NP
um like multiplications or or additions
so so you have to take all of n times V
time so basically the runtime depends a
lot on P it's linear in p and if p is
something like 10 to the nine then your
run time will be 10 to the nine
um times the number of samples you know
which is often prohibitive
so this is very very slow on on
empirically
if you do let's just implement this and
when D is a solid
any questions so far
okay so the main goal of this lecture is
to find out a way to speed up this
algorithm that's called the that's the
kernel trick what's the kernel tricks
about it's about to how to uh implement
this non-linear model
um using this idea better but but
implementing it in a way such that you
can be computationally efficient
so so the final algorithm will be
equivalent to this algorithm but it will
just be faster and actually much much
faster
focus on that like
whatever alternative
he is going to stay as the same
um
the second the we are gonna we are going
to try to implement this algorithm in
some other ways but but UCP will you
know I'm not sure whether I will say yes
to like you know we will do something
with fee yeah
foreign
so the the whole point of the the rest
of the lecture is to have a faster
algorithm
and you know maybe just a a side of
philosophical remark I think machine
learning is really a lot of about
machine learning is about computational
efficiency even though these days
sometimes you know like you can use gpus
right so but uh but I think at the heart
you know at least a good fraction of
machine learning is about computational
efficiency because many of these kind of
statistical questions in some sense you
can say they are studied
well in some sense like in in statistics
and and I at least
immersion learning I think at least
comparably comparatively I think we
focus a little more on computational
part
but the first competition is only one
part right so like you also have to care
about statistical perspective
um but I'm just saying that computation
is important you know it's not just a
merely uh or a separate thing that you
you can you can resort to an oracle so
in many things you have to really think
about computation because otherwise you
cannot Implement your algorithm you
cannot run your algorithm on a large
their side then you wouldn't see a good
result
um and and this is one way to speed up
things
um and we're gonna see other uh ways
okay so
um okay so how do we speed up this so
here is a key observation to speed up
this so
so the observation is that
um the Theta
can always
be represented
as
you know you may found this a little
kind of like a surprising at the first
start but I'm going to
um explain
so this Vector Theta can always be
represented as a linear combination of
the features
for
some scalar where this beta I is the the
scalars for the for the uh linear
combination so for some later one up to
Beta n
and each of these beta is in r
uh and okay I guess there's a condition
here so if
Theta 0 is 0.
so I guess I'm going to change just uh
for the sake of Simplicity I'm just
going to decide my initialization for
this algorithm is that Theta is equal to
zero it's initialized to zero
so then I'm not going to have this
condition
so I'm going to claim my algorithm I'm
going to say that my algorithm to start
with Theta is zero you know
initialization probably doesn't matter
that much right so because either way
you're going to update a lot of times
right so
um so if you start with zero then
in this algorithm no matter what time
stata can always be represented as a
linear combination of our features
so and why this is you know useful what
will be this useful you will see but
roughly speaking the reason why this is
useful is because Theta is a p
dimensional vector
right and I'm in a regime where p is
probably maybe just uh I'm thinking of
so I'm in a regime where regime
uh is that P is larger than n
so let's say p is really really big
extremely big right even bigger than n
so so Theta is a p dimensional Vector
which is extremely big but now you
represent this vector by the scalars and
you have unscalers
so so in some sense you have you reduce
the degree of freedom in your
application at least right so before we
have to represent store P numbers but
now you only have to store in numbers if
this claim is true
so so in some sense you will see that
you know I'll tell you more about
details in some sense you'll see that
the way we speed up this is that we
never store Theta explicitly we all we
always store the the representations of
data right the beta ice is my surrogate
for for phosphate and that's enough for
many of my computation
like is isn't the sum their escape this
is a scalar but this is a vector right
this is a pdmi stone vector
so this is scalar so so but you but you
don't have to store this because these
are already there in some sense these
are not changing even
right so only the beta will be changing
where beta is a surrogate Force Theta in
some sense so so
um so you don't have to store how data
changes and that implicitly tells you
how stata will change over time
we'll see exactly how this works
um
right so but maybe before going to that
let me just uh
um
show you why this this is true why why
this is true the reason is actually
relatively simple
um if you look at this so the reason is
that
pretty much you know in short in a
nutshell the reason is that every time
you update
you always update Theta bioscaler this
is this whole thing is a scale this
parenthesis is a scalar whatever scalar
it is you always update about scalar
times this vector v of x i
so basically every time you update your
update is of this kind of form it's a
linear combination field of exercise so
that's why you keep being keep having it
for
um if you want to prove that you know
um you know more formally I think the
kind of the statement you have to do the
induction so let me also try to do that
so by induction
so first of all you check at iteration
zero so at
uh iteration zero
so indeed our Theta is equal to zero
that's my choice of initialization and
this is indeed equals to a sum of linear
combinations of the the feature vectors
right because I just have to choose my
Beta I to be zero exactly
right
um that's easy
and maybe I can also just uh to build up
intuition let's also look at iteration
one even though I don't think this step
is necessary if you really care about
the formal proof this is just for
intuition and iteration one then what
you do you you update Theta to be equals
to the over Theta which is year zero
plus
um this gradient which is Alpha times
uh I from 1 to n
y i minus Theta transpose Phi of x i
feel facts I
and this thing you know
um is a scalar actually is equal to Y
because Theta is zero right Theta was
zero in the previous division so this
will be just y i
times V of x i
right Theta was zero and you plug in 0
here you get this so this is indeed a
linear combination of the feature
vectors right so this is a vector this
is a scalar and so Alpha times y I will
be my Beta I in this round
right so so this thing plus this thing
together
will be my maybe I'll just write Alpha
here
so if I write Alpha here then this whole
thing will be my Beta I
add iteration one
okay and you know for the future steps
you know I wouldn't I wouldn't be able
to explicitly write beta I that
carefully but I'm going to use the
induction right so so suppose
I'd iteration t
I already know that Theta is equals to
something like sum of beta I Phi of x i
I'm already this is my inductive
hypothesis
and then a next iteration
you can see that
Theta is updated to b equals to theta
plus Alpha
okay I'm just going to copy this formula
again
actually if you just I just want to
prove the induction I don't even have to
plug in what Theta is because
if I just care about induction right so
I know this is a linear combination
field of x i and this is a complete the
combination field of x i then the sum of
them will be linear combination of V of
x i but I'm going to do a little bit
more detail steps because these steps
will be useful for me as well uh so I'm
just going to plug in everything so I'm
going to plug I'm going to replace Theta
by
my inductive hypothesis
and then I'm going to replace this data
by my inductive hypothesis as well so
I'm going to have Alpha times
okay what is this so Theta is equals to
uh
let me see one moment there's something
okay I guess let me
maybe let me just skip this
okay so
and this is equals to
just the sum of faded eye
plus Alpha
y i minus Theta transpose Phi of x i
I didn't do anything really complicated
it's just a super simple uh manipulation
right I just
and now this whole thing
is a scalar whatever scalar it is this
will be my new
beta I
right in the next step
any questions
[Music]
yeah this doesn't work for randomization
and but you don't need to use but
actually in a position zero is actually
probably the best
um
maybe maybe there's some reason for this
but maybe let's discuss that uh offline
so initialization
um it does matter a little bit but but
let's say is we just take initialization
fees zero
Okay so
okay so now let's proceed with my plan
my plan was that I'm going to replace
so so so so far I just don't want to
prove the claim right the claim is that
I can always represent say that by Beta
and now I'm going to just only mention
beta
so so basically my plan is that I was
just only gonna maintain
beta but not say so so that means that
I'm going to start from so so P
parameters
before it was P Paris and now it becomes
n parameters
and if p is very large then this this
means some saving
so so that means that I have to
understand how the beta is changing
right so I have told you that beta
exists right so when beta is equal to
this but I want to have an update of
data that only so here right now beta
depends on Theta so you found to compute
beta the new beta I have to know the old
Theta which is uh which kind of defeats
the purpose right so if you have to know
what's the existing Theta then
um then you have to compute it right so
then um you raise the P time so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to find out how
does beta depend on beta itself without
going through a site
so that's uh what I'm gonna do so where
should I
Maybe
yeah I'll write down the left hand side
I guess maybe I'll just write somewhere
here so that there's some locality
uh
maybe I can erase this
so
so this is the update
for beta I
so how do I update beta I so beta I is
supposed to be equals to Beta I plus
Alpha
times this way times this so this is my
rule for my starting point I know that
beta is equals to Alpha times y i minus
Theta transpose Phi of x
I
but this rule is not great because it
does have sailor here so I have to
maintain Theta I'm going to get rid of
data by plugging the definition of theta
in terms of beta so this is equals to
Beta I plus Alpha times y i minus
what's the definition of theta so if you
the sorry what's the representation of
theta so Theta is equals to
this right this is the relationship
between Theta and the beta
this is a j because I'm having
some inside
and this transpose
times Phi of x i
and parenthesis
okay so
um and then I'm going to
continue so reorganize this a little bit
so I'm going to get
beta I Plus
Alpha times y i
minus
I'm going to
um put this inside so sum over J from 1
to n
beta J
Phi of x j
times Phi of x i
this means in your product right so a
transpose B I guess this is just a inner
product with speed
that's what I'm using so
and this is I and this is J
okay
so have I done okay so what I have
achieved I got rid of theta so now it's
a it's of the rule from beta to Beta
itself right so if you know the old beta
you can compute new bit
that's what this is saying but did I
really save any time
not yet right because if you want to
compute the new beta from the old beta
you still have to do this in the product
this inner product between two P
dimensional vectors still takes P time
and you still have the sum Over N
indices right so still of MP time so I
haven't really saved much just because
the fees still shows up here
however here is the Magic The Magic is
that
somehow
you can compute so
so this still takes off this is still of
MP time
right and this is uh so far not really
much saving
there are two things we can notice to to
make it faster so one thing is that this
inner product
um can be Pro can be pre-processed
okay
so you don't have to compute every time
right because this is just something
that doesn't really change over time in
your in your algorithm but over time I
mean in in the
as your algorithm is running right this
quantity is not changing at all right so
for every IJ right
the beta will be changing right so but
this wouldn't wouldn't be changing
so and another more important thing is
that so so this means that you can do it
once and you don't have to complete it
every time so at least you only have to
do it once in the very beginning
and another thing is that
oftentimes this inner product
actually can be computed faster
than you thought
right the trivial way to implement this
is that you just compute this Vector
this vector and you take inner product
but actually you can do some math to
speed up this in many cases
um
so this can be computed
without
even evaluating
fee explicitly
evaluate each of these factors you are
the waste p time but sometimes you can
do some math to not even evaluate the
fee that's what I'm going to show on
next
any questions
basically we are representing something
in the space of RP in terms of linear
combinations of vectors in order so
actually uh last number of factors than
the dimensional space itself so does it
make it all over approximation of the
initial results
where is it precise
um it's still precise because so far you
see that I have never done any
approximation
right but your question your question
definitely makes sense it's a very
logistical question right so why you can
somehow magically save money degree of
Freedom right I think the reason is that
um
this might be a little bit big at this
level but the reason is that even you
had this P dimensional
uh degree of Freedom key degree freedom
in a third time
when your data is not as large as P you
cannot use all of them you could it's
not it's not like you you are not
fundamentally using all the
dimensionality so or all the degree of
freedom in the face in some sense like
the if you have any samples the maximum
amount of degree frame you can have is
and that's why you can save even without
any approximation right so here it's
really to see a real implementation of
the same algorithm we didn't lose any
it's not like you're doing any
approximation
um
I think no I think you have to utilize
with beta0 be all of this only works
with easier initialization so so state
has to be tries to be zero and beta also
has to be initialized to be zero just
because that's the correspondence at the
beginning
right so then this wouldn't help you ice
probably would hurt you yeah we will
discuss a little but at the end like
when this will be useful I think this
will be useful only when p is really
really big
yeah but sometimes p is really a bit
like like in the case
um yes yes so so like um
so okay so if your question is like what
happens with my Beta Is Random I think
in most of the cases
maybe in all cases I don't know in most
of cases I think you probably would get
the same answer eventually
like when you run this algorithm in a
data space
but the correspondence is only
zero so there's another reason why like
okay so so maybe maybe here is the exact
answer to this so suppose you only care
about what happens with beta is run
initialized to be random then I think it
still can work and it can actually still
give the same
solution in most of cases is basically
zero initialized initialize to be zero
but that's that's a different reason
um that's a there's a different reason
for this to be true because just because
you're doing some complex compensation
eventually you always converge to the
same solution probably that's what you
are only
um kind of you you mean as well but this
correspondence between sailor and beta
you know on this level it only works for
beta is zero that makes sense
um okay any other questions
[Music]
we still have to calculate like we're
pre-processing it we're actually a
single combination right
right how is that speeding anything else
right so so so so that that means you
only have to do any Square pairs right
you know it doesn't you know
how does that so that still is a lot of
time I agree but the the difference is
that
if you do it on the Fly then you have to
do this all IG pair for every iteration
so I'm saying that comparatively this is
faster I'm not saying absolutely is very
fast so so suppose you do this inner
product every time then you still have
to do it for every inj because here you
have a j here you have some over J and
also you have to update for every eye so
so you basically have to do all of these
pairs for every
iteration so I'm saying that at least
you can save that at least you don't
have to do it for every it
will be higher than the number how many
iterations will we end up having
um the number of iterations I think
that's a little bit tricky like but but
let's say you know let's say you have
two iterations right so before you have
t times this number right and now you
just save that t
oh right that that's the only thing okay
the the biggest saving is probably come
from coming from here which I'm gonna
show
right now like like a each of these
inner products actually cheaper much
cheaper than than than we typically
think
okay so why that's the case so
um of course this is not like a this is
not a universal statement right it's not
like forever fee you can do this but for
many of the the fees that we designed or
that that makes sense that intuitively
makes sense then you can speed up and
actually later on this becomes a
principle you only design free such that
this is fast you don't you don't care
about any other fees
um but you know but let me say Let me
let me not get into there let me just
talk about this particular
what right so for this fee I'm going to
show you why this can be fast and and
the reason is very simple it's just that
you can do some math to to make your own
formula easier so so for the fee that I
Define here
so fee of x times Phi of Z
uh this what is this I'm taking I'm
abstracting a little bit I have x and z
just the two two things right you can
think of this as x i this as x j
um I'm just using more abstract notation
so this is just the inner product two
vectors you know one vector is one
um X1
up to x d x y Square so and so forth you
know and the other one is a column
Vector which is one Z One Z two up to z
d and Z1 Square so and so forth
right something like this
so and you just take the anchovies
product and take the sum
right so this times this will be one
this bunch of things times these bunch
of things
will be sum of x i z i i from 1 to D
okay
so now let's do the degree two parts
right the degree two monomials so this
will be so what are this coin this these
quantities right here the degree two
things so they're all of the form x i
and x j right
and here you have this bunch of these
they're all of the form z i z J
right and you take the corresponding
Paradox and take the sum so basically
what happens is that you Loop over all
the possible choices of I and J
and you take x i x j times z i z J
and then you do the you do it for the
degree three part which is the same so
you Loop over so all the degree three
parts there of the form x i x j x k and
on the other side you have the form z i
z j z k and you take the sum over all
possible combinations of i j k
so this is from 1 which is from 1 to B
okay so and now let's simplify this
and so you can simplify this by
So This One X this one we don't simplify
this is already pretty simple
um you can notice no otherwise you can
simplify x times Z but this doesn't
really change anything it's still the
same computation but then for the second
term what we can do is that we can we
have a two sub right we can
factorize the two sum so you can write
this as
you first take the sum over I you look
at all the terms that depends on I
that's a z x i and z i and then you also
have the part that depends on J
so
j z J so in some sense I'm just using uh
I've checked speaking I'm using the fact
that you know if you have sum of UI
times WJ where I is from 1 to D J is
from 1 to D then this is equals to sum
of UI
times sum of w j
right so that's just the formula I'm
using
an UI corresponds to
x i z i and u w j corresponds to x j
that's how I use this abstract formula
so
um
okay and then I can do the same thing
for the third one which will be equals
to
again you factorize based on i j k you
collect all the terms that depends on I
which is x i z i and you collect all the
terms it depends on J which is x j z J
and you collect all the terms it depends
on K which is uh x k c k
so okay what's good about this the good
what's good about this is that you know
you can see this one
and this one are actually the same thing
you use you are just changing the the
way you index the terms but but anyway
you are you are taking a loop some over
all the terms right doesn't matter what
indices you use and and the same for all
of this all of these are all the same
all of these are equals to X transpose X
in the product we see
so you find essentially what you get is
that
um essentially it's like a you know what
you got is just a x inner particle Z
Plus X inner product with z
square plus X in the Paradox with z
cubed
and why this is helping you in
computation the reason is that now
it takes
of D time
to compute
X commas inner product with Z right
that's that's of D time but now P right
this is just the your your raw feature
like your input dimension and then after
you get this you can take the power the
second power this one is a scalar right
after you get X in the power C you just
take a scalar Square you get this and
you take a scalar Cube you get this
right so so the whole runtime is really
just
X the time for doing this Plus
I think four or plus some constant
because you just take the power and you
take the cell
so so the total runtime is
total time is also of d
like a look or I'm ignoring the constant
you know I'm assuming D is big
any questions
so I guess like if we choose a fee
smartly and appropriately then we will
we might not even need to compute the
whole
do we we might not even need to put our
data set right right so here you don't
need right so here you don't have to
implicitly save fee because okay so
exactly that's a good question so
basically what so what happens right now
so basically you
compute this quantity but you don't have
to know what fears you just complete
this quantity using the using the
circuit and you compute them you compute
all of this in advance
and then you run this algorithm
so let me write down this more formally
so formally what you do is you
let me also introduce some notation to
kind of abstractify this because it will
be also useful
um
especially if you read other papers and
the related works so
um
there is a notation people call this
Define the so-called kernel function
is defined to be this precise at this
quantity we care about the inner product
between features
this is called kernel function
so this kernel function as the
definition shows is something like that
takes in two vectors and output a single
scalar
and
and the algorithm is just that
um
so if you use the kernel method
basically we have show you the steps but
now I'm going to group everything
together so basically the final
algorithm is the following
um maybe
here
so what you do is you say you first
compute you're pretty precise
all of the inner product so you you
compute K of x i x j recall that this is
defined to be the inner Paradox of these
two things
so you compute this for all
I and J from one to n
okay
um
and then you say
you have a loop
so I guess you start with say beta0
and so beta beta is a vector
in RN so beta is the collection of beta
1 after beta n and you start so you
start with better zero and then you do a
loop
and this Loop will just be something
like
uh
for every
I from 1 to n I'm going to use this
update rule for beta so what does that
mean that means that I'm going to
update beta I to be with I plus Alpha
times y i minus
sum of beta J
sum of beta J times this inner product
by this inner product which is something
I've computed and I denoted that by K
of
x i and x j
right so that's my algorithm
and and now we can take another kind of
like accounting to see what's the run
time for this particular
polynomial feature
so the runtime is let's see
okay so I guess you know you probably
can also got a runtime so to compute
this we are using the formula like this
right to combination part that we're
using this formula so for every pair
you need all of the type
so this is O of t
for IJ so of N squared D in total
hmm
[Applause]
right and here my runtime would be
um let me see
[Applause]
I guess I would I don't have it on my
nose somehow I don't know why
anyway but I can do it on the fly so you
already know this number
so basically you need to pay n times
to a time of end time to compute this
sum
and you also have to update
uh each of the this and each of the I
right so for every eye you have to pay
and time so totally this is all of n
Square time
and square time
per iteration
so the catch is that
there's no P involved anymore
whatsoever so you just only have n and D
um and if your n is small enough then in
some case you know as if n Square for
example is less than NP then you are
winning right recall that before when we
run this every iteration we have to take
n times P duration and now every
iteration we have to take an Square
iteration so if n is less than P then
you are winning and in many cases n is
much smaller than P just because P could
be a
D to the three right that's just a lot
of it
so
[Applause]
um at least I'm not saying this is
universally better when I'm actually I'm
only discussed you know when this
chronometer is better especially as you
can see it's better when p is very big
and small right but in those cases you
do save a lot of time
can you do update one day at each time
so I think that's that would that would
be called uh coordinate within this is
right because
each of the beta I
should be considered as a as a
coordinate of your parameter but that's
just terminology I think if you update
each of them one by one
um You probably have to use smaller
Alpha but in theory you should it should
still work if you small enough Alpha but
I don't think you would gain much by
doing
maybe you can gain a little bit but but
it wouldn't be a fundamental difference
you know maybe it will be faster a
little bit
any other questions
or what I'm adding squared or per
iteration
how many tuitions I need that's a little
bit hard to decide because it depends on
the problem and
um but so so that's why we only compare
per iterations so far
run time on my part
if each calculation C runtime
like the total is over and b square or N
squared B
plus o of N squared D times
I think I think I see what it means so
so if you really care about the total
the final final run time I think you
would call it something like
and Square D
plus of you know and
squared times T where T is the number of
iterations but what is T you know the
reason why I don't discuss like that is
because t uh is a little bit tricky like
it's a little bit uh
problem more problem dependent
um so so so that's why and um
yeah but it was a good guess for tea
it really depends on the problem
sometimes it's pretty small sometimes
it's it could be a little bit larger
um so so suppose you ignore the the
pre-processing time then you can compare
roughly speaking and compare the per
iteration runtime so maybe maybe the
first implicitly right so there's no way
to exactly compare everything exactly so
um unless you you have more
specifications of the problem but
roughly speaking though I think the idea
is that here there's no P showing up
so so so so it has to be better in some
sense it's it's kind of pretty easy to
be better than so for example p is
really really large I suppose p is like
10 billion right so whatever you do here
you probably it's going to be better
than something that has p in it
yeah so
um
what
so I think
and and this observation that you only
have to compute the inner product of
this of the features
um it sometimes has more profound kind
of implementation Implement uh
implication on the the thing is that you
know
when we realized that this inner
Paradise the only thing you care about
then
you start to wonder what do you really
have to think about what it feels so
maybe you just have to start with the
kernel
and then as the field so basically so
here is the um a change of mind side you
know that researchers have kind of in
some sense done in for this kernel
method so so so we started with the fee
and we defined a kernel but you can also
start with the kernel
so you say I'm going to define a
function like this
and then
as long as there exists a fee then you
are done because you don't have to know
what fee is
right so you don't have to know the
kernel is the inner part of something
but you but you really have to care
about those fees and the way it's not
implemented it's not used at all in your
algorithm right so so roughly speaking I
think one way to deal with do this is
you just Define K and you get you just
forget about V
and different points
um
[Music]
P dimensional space this p is greater
than M so isn't that this will be over
50 in this case so
yeah yeah yeah I think that's uh that's
a great question
um you don't necessarily have to overfit
but this is um
um the short answer is that you don't
have to you don't necessarily have to
overfit
um because uh
okay I guess you know I'm I'm using
languages that we haven't discussed in
this course like you like the norm of
your solution may not be that big like
even though the parameter of parameters
is a lot but you can have a small Norm
solution and that still can help you
generalize but this is something that uh
I don't think we're gonna discuss in
very much detail in this course even
though we're going to touch on this a
little bit but not much
okay so so basically let me just say you
know let me continue with the the this
change of mindset uh in some sense so
what what people do
um is that
you just forgot about a fee and you just
don't only work with the kernel because
the all the algorithms you know you
don't have to even know what fee is so
so basically you know one thing at least
that is tempted to do is that you can
use the Define okay and then you just
run this algorithm because after you
define okay you can run this algorithm
right but of course you know you cannot
just use a arbitrary hey because if you
use the arbor trick hey then your
algorithm doesn't have interpretation
you don't know what you are really doing
it's just the algorithm right so what
you really want is that you want okay
that
satisfies this
for some fee but you don't have to know
what exactly fee is
so so basically
I think so that means that you have to
understand in what cases you can Define
of K and that algorithm still makes
sense so so basically people call this
if K is a valid kernel
foreign
if
um there exists of a function fee such
that
K of X comma Z is equals to the inner
product
so so basically you can just design any
function K as long as you guarantee that
the existence of Phi as I always
guaranteed that this is a very kernel
then you can try to run that algorithm
and you know your algorithm is really
just doing a linear
linear model on top of the the feature
fee
but you don't have to know what V is
once we get these final because we'll
apply them to feed that free version of
the data and then we'll get the thetas
and formulas
that's a fantastic question that's
that's great so yeah I think I
I think I missed this small part I
forgot okay my back so but yeah but I
also you know um like yeah this is
exactly you know what let me talk about
this so the test time
you also don't need the fee that's the
thing so so the test time
by test time you mean I mean if you if
you give me a new data point x right so
give a new data point x
so the question is how do you compute
how to
compute
this thing
and the question was that you know it
sounds like you have to have to compute
feed in the Theta right
um from beta and then you you compute
this but actually you don't have to
because you can just plug in the formula
so Theta transpose field of X you use
the representation as much as possible
and and use math so so you try to
replace Theta by this linear combination
by the I times Phi of x i
so I suppose
Fairfax
and now it will regroup you found that
this is still about inner Paradox of two
six so this becomes sum of
beta I times the kernel function applied
on x i and X
so if your kernel function is evaluated
very fast then you don't have to know
what Phi is
okay that's a quick question thanks for
reminding me right so if you know okay
you can do the training you can do the
test
um and the only thing you have to
guarantee is that this K is a valid
kernel so that you are doing something
sensible
um by doing something sensible it means
that if you know it's a valid kernel you
know that you are doing linear
regression with the fee as the feature
so in some sense like a
there is a if you design a good fee
a good feature is kind of almost the
same as
designing a good k
because I know you don't know what fee
is good right or not right so probably
you should just go directly designing K
and advanced K is a very kernel you just
run it and see whether it's good or not
[Applause]
what is x i is
samples or like training samples
this is the treatment samples yes that's
a great question so X eyes are still the
chaining samples and an X is a test
example so it's interesting that in the
test time you still have to look at the
training example to do this
to do this test it's not like you have
you just have to remember
right right so so like in a typical case
you just have to store Theta and then
you don't you can forget about the
tuning site but now you cannot forget to
change that
so and I guess I have like 15 minutes so
I'll briefly discuss you know when do
you know this is a valid kernel because
this is so you need to have a way to
you know if you want to use this kind of
like equivalence and just forget about
hey you have to have some way to tell
whether your kernel is valid right in
some sense so
um and there are some mathematical
characterization of when the kernel is
valid this is uh um
um
uh let me write down the theorem
see
which sport did I
which one should I erase maybe this one
okay
foreign
there's a necessary and sufficient
condition
um so
[Applause]
so necessary condition
so so if K is valid
this implies that
okay maybe let's let me let me first
Define some notation
so in the in the literature people also
have you can Define the following
suppose you have X1 after accent
these are undated ones
Define the so-called
we still use the same thing in the same
notation I don't know why people do this
but so now this is with the abuse of
notation you define a matrix K I call it
kernel Matrix
and this Matrix is a unbatant
dimensional Matrix where k i j is equals
to
this K is the kernel function
applied on this
the parents of data I know this is a
little confusing I don't know why people
keep doing this like this is a on the
left hand side this is a matrix you
define a matrix based on the function
the kernel function so every kernel
function you can use that to Define
Matrix and this Matrix is basically the
evaluation of this kernel function on
particular data points
um you know if
I think probably you know we should just
call this came another thing like I'm
whatever you call it by so it's just
there are two different things but
people keep to seems to use the same
notation for the fault
um and
um what you know is that
so
maybe I'll just uh probably talk about
the
the full condition given that we don't
have a lot of time so unnecessary and
sufficient condition is that
if the k
so K is a
is a valid kernel function
so that means I'm talking about a
function but now the Matrix
foreign
this is equivalent to
for every
X1
an accent if you choose any examples
then the kernel Matrix
K this is a matrix that's defined like
this is PSD
is positive sum definite
um
one side of this claim is pretty easy to
show because from the value kernel to
this I think it's really pretty much
just a simple calculation so you just
plug in the definition that K is the
inner product of two feature functions
feature vectors and then you can pretty
much verify this current this Matrix PST
the reverse direction is a little bit
kind of tricky and and also my statement
of theorem I think I'm missing some
regulatory condition if you if you
really care about the exact math but but
this is like
up to a small manner regulatory
condition you have to say this K is
boundator like a continuous kind of
things
um
right so basically after you have this
theorem then the workflow is that
[Applause]
so in some sense kind of the workflow
is kind of like you first design okay a
kernel function
right there's a kernel function okay
and then you verify
K is valid
and how do you verify maybe you can use
the theorem above but that doesn't
really mean that it's easy because
you still have to
use this theorem in some way try to
prove that the kernel makes with PSD but
there are some ways to verify this or
you verify by either by using a serum
or just by constructing all by
constructing
the explicit
Feature Feature map
that make a valid so you do something
like this and then you just run your
algorithm
run on
you run this algorithm
that we defined somewhere I guess here
um with k
and
and they are so but here we are using so
how do we get this algorithm we are
using the regression loss right we are
using the square loss and linear model
right but you can also kind of like use
other uh starting point for example
suppose you start with logistic
regression
with the feature and then you can do the
same kind of like operations like we
have done and then arrive at a different
algorithm in the kernel space
so in some sense this is called kernel
trick so basically a kernel
trick or sometimes if you call this kind
of kernelite kernelized
it means that you turn an algorithm so
you turn
an algorithm
uh uh into into this algorithm
like algorithm about
Phi Phi X into a algorithm
uh about okay
this kernel function so so you may start
with logistic regression with VX as the
feature and then you can do you know I'm
not I didn't tell you how to do it but
you can do the same type of kind of
derivations as we have done today to get
another algorithm
um that only uses K and the algorithm
would look something like this but not
exactly the same a little bit different
and and if you can do this then you you
say but not all the algorithms can be
turned it can be can be can be done in
this way like a like a not all the
algorithms is a mean about this
so-called kernel trick so some
algorithms is possible some algorithms
not possible
um I think in the homework we have this
perception algorithm for homework too
um which can be turned uh into into
kernel uh kernel can be kernelized uh I
guess I'm already kernelized
um or you can apply the kernel trick and
now just the question I think you can
apply chronologic
um but some of the other algorithms if
you use L1 organization if you have
heard of it we have I know we haven't
talked about L1 organization but some of
the other algorithms cannot be colonized
just because your algorithm so okay and
also maybe one thing why in what case
you can kernelize this so like a kind of
the key is that everything can be
written
like the only way you use the features
are about the person of product between
two data points the features that do two
data points if your algorithm somehow
can be turned into a way such that the
only thing you care about is this then
you can kernelize it because just
replace this by the kernel but if your
algorithm
cannot be written in a way such that the
entire algorithm only cares about this
inner product then you wouldn't be able
to chronologize
um
right
okay and then let me also briefly say a
few words about some of the other
kernels right so only show you one
kernel on some of the other kernels
include
um
they are actually not that many you know
sometimes
um they are not the many general ones
but sometimes for like the particular
applications you can design particular
kernels that looks
um that they are useful for you so
um so some of the kernels are something
like for example
uh we have defined this you know
k x z which is something like
you can for example this is a something
that is very similar to
what we have so
KX is equals to X in the product we see
plus C to the power
k
so for any choice of c and k
uh this is a kernel
um and actually you can write this as
something like
um
for case two I guess I actually know so
far
okay it's two actually I even know
what's the feature the feature is
something like this
C square root 2C
X1 square root 2 c x two
so and so forth and X1 square up to XD
Square you don't have to know exactly
what is this like I don't even remember
but but but for this case you know for
case two you can write the explicitly
what the the features are and for other
case you can also write explicitly what
what they are
um but you don't have to carry that much
about it right you only have to know the
existence of it and then we run it you
just use this kernel and another kernel
is called gaussian kernel
which is something like
exponential minus x minus Z Square
over to Sigma Square here this is two
norms
so and this one you can also write it as
an inner product
between C of X and Phi of C
but this fee will be much more
complicated actually you can construct
oh sorry yeah you can construct a
expensive fee such that this is true but
this construction will be very
complicated and also another thing is
that this has to so fee has to be
infinite dimension
so sometimes you can fee has to be even
infinite dimensional vectors you know I
I know we we didn't talk about what
exactly the infinite dimensional Vector
really mean but but that's kind of the
idea so you have to really use a lot of
Dimensions
um to
um to to express this kernel but you
don't really have to know what what's
the what are exactly the fees are
because when you run the algorithm you
just don't care about this right so so
in some sense this so this is the way
that we can deal with info and
dimensional features so
so if your features that it's not a
problem
like as long as your inner product
between two features can be computed
efficiently then the dimensionality of
the features just don't matter like uh
it can be very large or it could be like
infinite it doesn't really matter
foreign
people think of this you know features
as a similarity metric where you can
think of this this function as a way to
measure x and z
um of course you know that's just the in
some sense that's the in interpretation
or intuition
um so
um when x and z are
similar I think at least in this case
you know when accessory are similar you
look at a larger number so that's why
you can think of as a similarity Magic
um all right so maybe a final comment is
that you know how do you think about
this kernel trick in the modern
by more than I mean like in the last
five years or last 10 years so you can
see that
like the runtime here right so they
always depends on N Square actually it's
always N squared so so you save a lot uh
in terms of the P the dep dependency you
just even get rid of the P dependency
completely but you what you lose is that
you get N squared instead of n recall
that before when you have
um like the vanilla way to implement it
you get n times P the p is there but
earn the power of only is only what
right so but now the the power on N is
two so
which means that you know if your own is
very large then this n square is
actually a bad thing right and square is
much worse than n so you lose a lot in
terms of the dependency on n and this is
probably one of the reasons why kernel
method is not
um used a lot you know these states you
know just you know that's that's one
reason I don't think it's a fundamental
reason is I don't think it's the the
most important reason but it's a it's a
it's a it's a it's a it's one of the
reasons so the reason is that in these
states you know your data set is at
least in some applications and it could
be like a million and when you have a
million square that's like 10 that's
like a a trillion right so that's just
prohibitive so um so that's the the
problem but of course there are also
also other ways to speed up this a
little bit like if you really uh care
about the runtime
so that's the second reason why the
kernel method is not used as often as
before is that
um all of this requires a design you
have to design your K or fee right so
whatever you do is it's really a hot
so-called handcrafted feature right you
do Define a function fee yourself
um you know you can you can choose them
but it is it's by human design I already
designed okay so when you do
um at least one way to interpret uh what
new right work will do is that
um we I know we didn't discuss new
artworks but I assume some of you know a
little bit but
um generally you know on High level
um
at least one way to interpret why the
right work is better is is is that you
can say new network is actually in some
sense learning this function fee so so
as you will see I think when you have
new artworks
in some sense you can view this as a
model as something like Theta transpose
fee
of X but this Phi of x is parametrized
by maybe let's call them some parameter
w
so so you can view the video networks
like this so it's a still a linear
function on top of some feature but this
feature itself
is learnable based on the data so so you
have a learnable feature instead of like
handcrafted feature and that's one you
know one of the many intuitions why new
artworks can can do better and and but
we do see this very often so these days
we have a lot of this kind of Feature
Feature extractors that are learned by
data
um and more and more more of this and
and if you use them then you just um
um like it's much much better than just
a random uh much much better than the
kind of those polynomial features we
designed
um on like in this lecture
um okay I guess that's all I want to say
for today
um thanks